hey guys this is Dennis the founder of
fake Terra and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of house of cards
season 2 Netflix
yeah a Netflix original series Kevin
Spacey where I've been trying
emmy-nominated Golden Globes yeah yeah
it's their flight so I really liked the
first season I think I put it in my top
5 shows of last year I have to say this
season I still really liked it didn't
like it as much as season 1 I'd agree I
think I might have even liked a little
less I I liked it up and I really liked
CFS ode 5 on top of this you and I about
I love the War Reenactment episode that
there's some really good moments but
then the show starts this my issue with
the house of cards is it tries to do
these moments from my chair just trying
to shock you or not like I guess we can
go right in so we're gonna go ahead and
display this here so if you haven't seen
you know season 2 then turn us off but
let's talk about Zoe Barnes
yeah right now the bigger issue with
than I did actually minded but the
season kept going I started to have more
of an issue with it because what house
of cards does is they'll give you a
shocking moment will never come back to
it Zoe Barnes you know killed her like I
guess they're trying to uncover some
secrets about him but like we never like
I want to see like his emotional
reaction to Zoe Barnes like what did
that do to him as a person but we're not
gonna see that of course the weird
threesome scene that you warned me about
again happens happens in that set just
happens no going back to it that I like
those it Fang or the Chinese business
yeah I liked his character weird sex
stuff
oral asphyxiation got a guy on a girl
going down on him at the same time no no
talk about that you know I like that
they hit on these really interesting
points and some of these scenes are
shock value but I'm like why don't we
explore those more and that really
bothered me about the season they did a
lot of weird things but never came but
did you notice that I mean did that
bother you at all I mean well the
reasons why that the Zoe Barnes thing
and three something bothered you know
more I think maybe from a different
angle or perspective than you is that it
bothered me because I didn't find them
believable I don't find that Frank
Underwood killing Zoe Barnes in that
situation at that time very believable I
mean
they're down in the subway station with
lots of people around cameras she didn't
really have anything on him yeah he
seems more calculated than that yes he
his care it's not within his character
right if he was just like some crazy
whatever that you know didn't have any
power and one did like was angry because
he was a jealous lover right and pushed
her in front of a train okay but then he
would be arrested and whatnot right this
is someone that has political influence
has all these things going on he can't
think of a better way of getting rid of
her right or even even killing her like
last season they his killing of
what's-his-name Russo yeah yeah to me
that was on the edge for me I was I who
I don't know but at the same time it's
possible cuz it was put in a situation
where he was on that guy almost killed
himself
anyways on accident right and he just
kind of reset it and also there it was
like late at night nobody's around you
know I mean so I could I could buy that
you know I didn't it wasn't a hundred
percent sure but this with Zoe Barnes
push her in front of a train like I just
thought it was very I don't know it just
seemed probable to me right and then
with the threesome thing also I just
found like okay it's nothing but through
some couldn't happen it could happen I
guess but it's like let's get don't just
show that and then just skip to the next
story it's like let's study this I think
the show bounces around too much mean
that really bothered me see for me it
could happen but there would be
repercussions that someone would find
out that's why I didn't like the
threesome was that okay here's a Secret
Service agent that works for the
restaurant he's supposedly off-duty
right that's why he can hang out and
drink it and get drunk
yeah well if he's off duty there's other
Secret Service guys around yeah somebody
has to replace him yeah mm-hmm
they're not gonna find out or see
anything or notice anything I just don't
buy it yeah maybe when he was just you
know the majority winner hmm and he
didn't have that and he just had like
Douglas Stamper around you know right
okay
but he's the vice president
all this stuff you saw all the stuff
they put into his house right in order
to you know protect him because remember
he didn't want to move to wherever he
was supposed to move to and then I mean
let's go look at another major character
that I felt was misused but had
potential let's go to Doug Stamper I
liked his character I like the actor I
think he does a great job the time in
this show when I was most interested in
him was when he went to investigate what
was going on the casino there was in
Kansas City I think or something like
that at the casino and he met that other
girl there who he sleeps with to get
information but they also had that
really nice discussion about Holly we've
been sober I think she was sober for
like maybe a year six months or
something he'd been sober for 15 years
really cool discussion and I liked that
about him but it's all obsession with
his girl from last season who really
didn't do anything interesting except
you know she goes to this fellowship
thing comes a lesbian that's all good
whatever I'm fine with that but it's
just and then she kills him at the end
with a with a brick or a stone whatever
it's like I just it's against that these
stories don't they just don't come
together well at the end that really
it's a really good show with great
acting but there's just times when I'm
watching this and I just don't think the
story comes together I don't think there
should be like I don't care about that
girl over there who's relocating to
living in wherever in Maryland I don't
why I just don't think you need shocking
things just to shock the audience let's
kill Doug Stamper why that's how I felt
like Joey Barnes like I felt like they
did it to shock the audience right
instead of tell a story I'm not gonna
spoil it but there's a there's a lot of
shocking things in a show like Game of
Thrones sure however everything leads to
that yeah it's within characters
decisions and the plot and the story and
it's almost like it's shocking but it's
almost inevitable and when it happens
you see the repercussions of that you
see the rubbery questions and you also
saw everything that led up to it you
know why that happened right mm-hmm like
I said I'm not gonna spoil it but
there's things that happened and you're
like oh my god that happened right but
you know what that makes total sense
because of this ABC and D House of cars
not so much why did they pushes okay you
know why did they kill her I still don't
understand what she had
was such a big deal that he he couldn't
manipulate or he seems smarter than that
yeah he's smarter than just pushing a
girl in front of a train yeah but yeah
again and I do like this show I think
it's a very good show it's just but
there are times and I'm watching I'm
just like I don't know maybe it's almost
like a soap opera a little bit now it
seems like to me I don't I I think it
thinks it's smarter than it I don't
think it's that I thought I don't I
would not put this above madmen I don't
think it's smarter than that I think it
thinks it might be better than watching
that man man to make that day or even
Breaking Bad yeah it's nice shuttle
enough it's too like sometimes it's too
in-your-face but I'm not sure why I
don't know all right well let's get to
the positives because I did really like
I do really like the show and I did like
the season it was just these these
strange to me out of place moments so
yeah the acting is fantastic Kevin
Spacey's great Robert writes amazing as
well you know the whole scene where
she's being interviewed on live
television and she reveals that she was
raped right what's great about that see
if she does what a lot of people do
which is they mix the truth
yeah halfway through this and mix them
all together so she mixed her the
abortion start with the rape stuff and
it's all true but she merges them
together for her political yeah benefit
but at the same time you can see she's
kind of breaking in the sense of she
doesn't want to lie about certain things
but she also doesn't want to tell the
whole truth and and and to you know go
into Kevin Spacey I mean he's he's
hamming it up big-time he's super hammy
but he's great at it you know he's like
you see a little bit of it with what's
his name on the blacklist the seasons
kind of doing that too a little bit
James Spader's kind of hamming up to
this is a better version of that you
know Kevin Spacey is such an amazing
actor that when he's hammy
he just does it so well and you just you
want to see what he's doing you want to
see what he's up to and he's such a bad
guy he's not a good guy and even when he
tries to care about somebody like I love
the part with him and Freddie right the
barbeque yeah I like Freddie's like look
man you're just a good customer you know
it's a pretend you were my friend you
know I don't you don't need to like act
like you really care about me you were
just a good customer Kevin Spacey was
great yeah those moments I really like
because it's kind of this thing
no he actually did care about you but at
the same time he cares more about
himself in all the political stuff and
and also there's you know there's just
other great moments of this what I like
about the show is the political
maneuvering and all that type of stuff
you know you have him trying to to
basically on one hand try and pretend
he's the a good friend to Garrett Walker
the president but at the same time he's
he's behind the scenes trying to tear
him down so he can be President so like
I like all of that type of stuff and you
know we had a great edition of Molly
Parker as as Jackie sharp she was a
great addition to this cast she takes
over as the the Majority Whip
which you know Frank Underwood he's the
one who positioned her into that into
that role and I thought she was really
good because she also had to make some
you know yeah sacrifices and you know go
against you know what she felt was right
in order to get I like her relationship
with Remy yeah Danielle I've got to see
his character a little bit more to that
he is basically a gun for hire but you
know he's having second thoughts about
things you know and yeah I mean you've
got emotion mixed in with with ambition
and its power money like for Frank it's
not about money you can tell us Frank
it's not about money
he's not trying to become the richest
man in the world he once said the most
power like every time Fang from China or
you know the other guy that the the
Warren Buffett like character was oh uh
Raymond Raymond tusk would come out and
be like look you guys are another
Deadwood a little bit right it's like
you would have the billions but I
control the worlds like most powerful
army like you would always come back
with I can push the button and end you
whereas you have billions of hours your
billions mean nothing to me yeah for
someone that you know is the vice
president he lives in this you know it's
a nice place a nice place but it's not
like you know who's not yeah it's not
like a multi-million dollar mansion
right yeah so yeah it isn't about the
money you know he likes to go go on his
runs yeah you know they don't really
live they obviously live well well but
they're not living lavishly no no so
yeah it is about the power I mean he
doesn't like someone having something
over him yeah which Raymond tusk was
that was it was really even though he
was trying to tear down the president it
was really raiment us that he was
butting heads with right but it was
through the president who happened to be
in the way yeah I happened to be in a
way so I like that that stuff you know
him trying to battle Raymond tusk
you know trying to work with Congress
trying to get bills passed but for
political reasons yeah not for his own
like moral rear-ends Oh some other
characters too again you know it's good
season but you have stuff like the
hacker yeah you know and as little as
guinea pig I didn't care about that
story I don't care if he goes to jail
for a hundred years or not doesn't
bother I'm fighting the system it's I
can't we seen this before it's nothing
and even the guy the the news reporters
my god that got caught I thought it's
like went in jail like the story is
really it's tusk it's the president and
it's kind of exactly great so that's
perfect Sneed to like that either like
get rid of a few of them a few of them
well get some working to do like Remy's
good Molly Parker's great but some of
them the hacker it's like and also with
the hacker and the ex-boyfriend you know
got cotton put in jail that was like a
side story of the Zoe Barnes death which
I didn't care for so to me like it just
doesn't the whole that whole thing just
doesn't work so yeah let's get back to
to the good stuff which is which is all
the actual political you know trying to
get people on his side they're like the
the chief of staff and you know the
secretary you know Secretary of State
and stuff like that and now I love the
the final scene when he walks into the
office and he asks you know Clare to
come in with him because we did this
together you can see her counter for
luck and she's like no I'm gonna go be
something Nelson I think he hesitated
before he walked in one it's what he's
always wanted but he's also very alone
now he's even told the president they
had a conversation during the season
where he's like the price of the
presidency is loneliness yeah and now he
is really isolated but also has all this
power so we saw Claire have that moment
on the stairwell where she was I just
got a portray there's just crying she
broke down she broke down because
she had a the president's wife really
say you're a good person you know there
no she's not a good president and she
knows that she's been manipulative even
her and though that's what's what I do
like about the show is this that the
downfall of Garrett Walker the president
is that he was too much of a good guy he
was weak you what let's see one I wasn't
ooh my friends like he wouldn't take you
wouldn't take the lead he always want to
here with his friends well there was
touch it was more of a Boy Scout you
know he didn't want to get down and
dirty he didn't want to you know he you
know he did want to keep his power he
wanted to be liked but at the same time
he didn't want to do any of the dirty
off that's what Frank did that's what
tusk wasn't afraid to do fang those guys
weren't afraid to get dirty they need to
get dirty and that that led to his
downfall
right I mean he if you want to play
dirty he would have taken the letter
right the confession that their Frank
and underwood sent him and he would have
brought it out but he is and I think
that was a calculated risk when Frank on
nowhere has sent him that confession he
said okay I can send him this thing he
can use it against me right I don't
think he will right I think he will see
this as a genuine gesture we get wasn't
he gamble but he gambled that that
Garrett Walker was a better person than
right yeah because if it was him and the
shoes on the other foot he would he used
that thing right off oh yeah definitely
I'll look he confessed to it he that he
it's all his fault yeah but he he took
that gamble as a gamble that paid off
and you know I mean we do know that they
are gonna be I think filming a season
three I believe in late spring early
summer so we all get season three we're
gonna be able to see Frank as the
president Claire as the first lady now I
wonder what I'm curious about because of
all this stuff that we talked about in
season one or season two now will any of
that come back or will in a lot of what
I've known about the show house of cards
fashion will they just kind of forget
about Zoey will that even come back well
the hacker come back well I don't it
will this girl unless Jenny know her
name the one who killed Doug which that
really a retro polish it's like a big
arc next season
Doug Stamper then Rachel Posey see I'm
sorry she's not that interesting to me
I'm huh I don't know but I feel like
story wise
this has two seasons left it I think
yeah you can't I think you can go I
think with the character Frank Underwood
I think because he is very forceful and
he does know what he wants I think as a
president he's gonna start off very well
yeah it's gonna be well liked he's gonna
make political moves that may piss off
certain people but we'll get things done
get things done and at first he will be
very well liked but I think because he's
so dirty that a lot of things will come
back to haunt him a lot of you know
things will come up against him and
that's where we'll start to see his
downfall probably towards the end of
season three right and maybe into season
four maybe he the ultimate like he gets
arrested goes to jail or something like
I couldn't I think he declares gonna get
hurt or Clare is gonna step away from
him a little bit I can't see her because
he had that breakdown I don't think her
resolve as the strongest is because he
very rarely doubts himself and he's very
confident to see him breaking down as
much but she broke down and I think
she's gonna back down before he was
she's more conflicted I mean I saw with
the whole how they're trying to change
the military she was passionate about
yeah rules about sexual assault and
stuff like that she was trying to get
that done for good reasons even though
she is also playing the political game
you know having that girl and so she
does have she kind of has both sides but
she is more much more conflicted than
than Frank mm-hmm so overall what are
your thoughts and what's your grade for
house of cards season two I'll give this
season
I'll give it a B I really like the first
five episodes I think as the second half
of the season started to go a lot of
these things that's kind of threw at us
these crazy scenes that didn't go
anywhere kind of bothered me I just
didn't know it kind of took me out of
the show a little bit but the
performances are excellent even with
date without David Fincher directing an
episode the season his presence can
still be felt the look of the show it's
a well-made show in the acting is just
top-notch some of the best acting you'll
see on television so yeah definitely
I'll give it a B definitely a must-see
yeah despite not like me as much as the
first season I still really liked it
despite
actually those two big things that we
were talking about earlier I'm gonna
give it a B+ because yeah the acting is
fantastic and some of the character
development character moments are great
just you know just take out some of
those you know trying to shock you a
moment that they really didn't serve
anything take out the hacker story line
that you know the Rachel Posner stuff
right you know in in the core of the
political maneuvering with Raymond tusk
right carrot walk the President Frank
Underwood and all that stuff that stuff
is the best right stuff about this show
and I think hopefully next season they
concentrate more on that right instead
of trying to shock us yeah exactly yeah
I just get down to the it's not the good
stuff yeah
all right guys so that's what we thought
of house of cards season two you can
post your comments below on the website
thank eurocom and on our youtube page
think carol pearl make sure to subscribe
to that i don't travel those with Dennis
Dennis and I on Twitter let us know what
Netflix shows you're watching us a lot
other shows out there's a little horror
show called Hemlock Grove you got this
one we got oranges new black coming back
on June 6th
we're excited to see that you can find
us at think hero I'm at Griffin de and
we all saw the Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans and
make sure you like that page and share
our videos on Twitter and Facebook
thanks
you